all right you are tuned into rocking
with the rook as always these videos are
brought to you by advanced diagnostics
USA
we are in a 2019 ram rebel new body
style
new smart key and we are going to be
doing key programming with the advanced
diagnostic smart pro now in this one you
have to plug into the star connector
using the advanced diagnostics 2011
cable and the star connector is driver's
side right up to your left just plug
into an empty slot first we will select
erase you sure you want to erase keys
yes keys program zero so that was pretty
quick and then we're gonna select
program keys
and please follow the instructions
carefully and complete the procedure
within 60 seconds okay little bit of a
text issue
get that resolved but what you do is you
hold the left corner of the smart key
and push down there you go so a couple
of flashes until it's programmed so left
corner of the smart key hold the
push-to-start button down until it's
programmed keys programmed one track ago
bada-bing bada-boom
[Music]
nineteen ram rebel keep programming with
the advanced diagnostics morrow